de petites écoles communales lorsqu'elle
en cours n'était encore qu'un village
l'ancienne mairie se transforme en
médiapôle un lieu de formation numérique
pour les scolaires et leurs enseignants
il suffit simplement de positionner
l'écran au niveau de l'image et la vidéo
se déclenche
armé d'une tablette et de la réalité
augmentée
élèves et professeurs peuvent se
déplacer dans cette salle flexible et y
découvrir ses secrets des connaissances
supplémentaires aux outils pédagogiques
novateurs là l'objectif c'est de
découvrir toutes les possibilités
d'aménagement dans une classe flexible
ans avec la possibilité pour les élèves
de bouger de se déplacer d'être en
mouvement parce que c'est pas forcément
acier ou immobile qu'on apprend le mieux
donc se découvrir qu'on peut travailler
autre monde
inauguré le 24 juin ce média paul répond
à l'ambition d'une éducation numérique
pour tous fortement portée dans le
département et dans l'agglomération 100
comptant en yvelines se veut actrice les
enfants quand on regarde l'impact chez
eux le ca augmente leur créativité
numérique ça augmente leur autonomie et
ça augmente leur confiance en soi trois
conditions très importante pour
augmenter les résultats scolaires
l'objectif c'est de c'est à la fois de
parfaire la formation des enseignants
qui est une formation continue
la technologie évolue les outils et
voulu donc les usages doivent évoluer
d'une part et c'est aussi de porter ces
enseignements directement au coeur des
classes en accueillant des classes et en
les accompagnant dans leurs
j'ai la ville d'elancourt est reconnue
comme une pilote et laboratoire
d'expérimentation en matière d'éducation
numérique depuis 2003